there is nothing better than a beer at
the campsite but beer is very heavy so
it can be hard to justify hauling a
whole six-pack out into the wilderness
that is the backpackers dilemma and this
is a pretty clever solution to that
problem it's called the portable
beverage carbonator it's by an outfit
called Pat's backcountry beverages you
think of it like a SodaStream except
it's for beer and it's small and light
enough that you can stow it in your pack
here's how it works you've got two
little reactor packets one with citric
acid the other with potassium
bicarbonate and these bru packets which
are full of what's basically beer
concentrate you put a little bit of
water into your main drinking vessel
then you add your concentrate and then
you finish adding your water to this 16
ounce line the reactor packets go in
here pump this full of the water that
you put in there earlier and shake like
this not like this that's important
that's enough let it sit for a minute in
the way that you add that gas to your
beer is by unlocking the reaction
chamber
you can see it kind of fizzing up
bubbling like that as we will head up
top you take this off
and you enjoy your beer
that is not terrible
definitely something I would bring with
me on a backpacking trip I don't know
how to have it on any old weekend hangin
out around the house but I would totally
be willing to bring this into the
backcountry